what a look is there a way to look any
better I don't think
so it is
6:05 a.m. for day five of
chemotherapy coffee's ready but I now
start my day with an enterade if you are
in chemo or going to be in chemo highly
recommend you invest in these this is a
medical drink that helps manage
digestive imbalance reduce fluid loss
stool frequency and stool volume
associated with diarrhea and it helps
hydrate rebuild and protect the gut
lining specifically a dietary management
of GI dysfunction during cancer
treatment so now I start my day with one
of these every day and a probiotic so
let's do
that it tastes
[Music]
okay we're going to have a good day it's
going to be a weird day zit sticker zit
sticker because we want to look good
when we're putting these chemicals in
our body also I've been obsessed this
entire time throughout treatment with
banana pancakes like a pregnant woman
with a craving like I have them every
single day so I'm going to make myself
some banana pancakes to either eat
before I leave or take with me I'm
whispering cuz it's early and Elliot's
still waking up and my mom introduced me
to this Kodak brand of pancake mix that
has 15 grams of protein in it so protein
is hard to get
when you're not feeling well during this
treatment but not if you're just making
Banana Pancakes every morning like a
neurotic little
weirdo I cook them with a lot of butter
in the pan so the edges get really
crispy probably not good for me but I
love it wow see look at all that butter
makes it so crispy this is today's fit
feels appropriate it this is the other
hat option that I will be bringing with
me courtesy of M's new friends from
weekend at vivs thank you so much look
at this human billboard of
cheeky
morbid
sentiments really like good pump up
music for the ride over okay we're in
the car cool there's a police officer am
I going to get in trouble for vlogging
in not a police officer excuse me oh
mind to say we are in the car on our way
to round five of chemo which honestly
feels very strange to process because
after this there's one more what are
your preemo thoughts cool Denny's
Denny's I don't know babe what do you
think I feel lots of different feelings
I'm so excited that it's round 5 I'm
nervous for obviously all of the
aftermath that happens after every chemo
day and I have to take a Sho so there is
a variety of competitive feeling ings in
my body how about
you same all three yeah yeah all right
well Hematology Oncology Center of
Beverly Hills we're about to come on in
and take over your bathrooms it has
begun I can't hear sh my head is in the
freezing State the first half power of
pke capping because like you would have
a brain freeze at your thought and we've
started our
premedication so let's do it I can't
tell if I'm talking loud or not loud I
have an air conditioning unit to my left
curious liquids goinging in my body on
my right what a time to be
alive this is the part of the infusion
where I hold ice bags on my hands and
feet to prevent neuropathy everything's
frozen
look at this disgusting looking
delicious brought from home tin of
Pancakes what's your do it's very very
cold in here today Min back that my head
is frozen up
to three blankets
but only an hour and 5 minutes for this
to cool down before we can get off the B
of here
oh my God round five is officially over
look at this hair wow that means there's
only one round left I'll be
honest I feel weird after that round I
feel my stomach feels a little weird and
I feel a little dizzy uh my head was for
sure Frozen that whole time but um very
glad it's another one down and we have
literally one left that's crazy let's go
sit in a frustrating amount of traffic
before we can celebrate Okay so we've
been back from infusions for a couple
hours and I'm
definitely more tired than I have been
immediately after infusions before so
it's definitely getting harder each
round who could have possibly guessed
with my little bit of energy I just
smoked a little bit of a joint I took
this little lady on a w oh she sleepy
now and I'm making myself some simple
food I'm trying this recipe for a no
cream potato
soup made with coconut milk we'll see
how it goes last week I made myself a
regular potato soup with like heavy
cream and it was delicious but I don't
know what it did to my body after that
so we're going to try no cream and see
how that goes wow I cannot believe that
we finished five of six infusions like
it really hasn't hit me yet I posted
said about it on Instagram and that made
it a little bit more real but wow I
cannot believe that there's only one
left I oh man it makes like I'm I'm too
tired to cry about it but I feel very
emotional about it because these are
getting fing difficult
and at one point I really wanted to quit
after four but longterm thinking I can
do it I can do six and we're doing it
there's only one more left and that
makes six okay I got a 10 to my soup
okay update
the bread is almost done update the no
cream potato soup is delicious and this
man on 90day fiance is insane okay it's
Thursday that means hydration day we're
back baby no BLT shots this time what
are you getting up to over there no
that's not right he's decided he's doing
all of my needles today oh good morning
it is Friday FR after hydration I'm
feeling pretty good I did one of the
main things on my uh to-do list today I
took a shower and guess what making
banana pancakes because we can't stop
and we won't stop and I put pumpkin pie
spice seasoning in today so uh-oh breast
cancer Grace is getting a little Wily in
the kitchen oh she's feeling a little
good she's probably going to exhaust
herself good morning it is Saturday um
I'm in slow motion today
I slept for 12 hours last night that's
crazy and I'm doing something psychotic
I'm making Banana
Pancakes cuz I now they've just become
like this Comfort meal first thing in
the morning that I look forward to I
will probably hate these by the time I'm
done with chemo that's what they say
Don't eat food that you love while
you're going through cancer treatment
because you will associate it with this
experience and you'll hate it but this I
love so much and I added pumpkin pie
spice to it and it just feels like I'm a
fancy fancy lady so we're going to do
that today and then we're going to sit
on the couch for the rest of the day
probably I can't believe I slept 12
hours Welcome to The Fabulous Life of
fatigue it is truly an unbelievable
experience okay go Birds they have a buy
this week I know football speak it is
Sunday we're in chemo round five
recovery honestly this one's not that
bad they reduce my chemo by 20% and they
took out the medication that causes all
the diarrhea and usually by this day I'm
pretty bad in bad shape and I'm only
slightly bad it's this weird bad where
like you feel just like hung over and
gross you feel awake enough to feel
gross and you you feel too gross to do
anything productive or helpful in your
life sounds pretty negative yeah I did
make banana pancakes again this morning
because I refused to not be psychotic if
I have to be sick it's now 1:10 in the
afternoon I've been sitting here in this
Nook of the couch pretty much all
morning um I brought a book over into my
area
to perhaps read a book I'm trying not to
just like scroll endlessly on my phone
because oh man when you don't feel well
and you're just scrolling on everyone
out there doing what seems like the most
fun thing to be doing that does not feel
good my red blood cell count is low so
my doctor told me that it's like I'm at
a different altitude than everyone else
is okay
checks out because I have been feeling
like I've had trouble breathing here and
there but I thought it was just anxiety
turns out no it's just the hemoglobin
but yeah I'm tolerating this this is
fine it's a lot of just this for anyone
that's sick I guess you know watch time
go by figure out how to make time go by
normally I wouldn't have the energy to
even Vlog any of it but I thought while
I had some energy I would show you this
part of it not a lot of bells and
whistles going on in this part which is
for the best because whoa hello Elliot
walked in on my vlogging so I stopped
vlogging but it's okay because I didn't
really know what else I was vlogging
about okay here's the deal I don't know
if I'll use this clip why not it's real
it's Monday night now I just got some
new blue blockers clearly that I love so
much look they take up like the majority
of my face how great is that it's like
I'm wearing a helmet on my face but I
can still breathe some sort of barrier
between me Behind These Eyes and the
outside world yeah I did smoke a little
bit of a
[Music]
joint it is Monday night it's 8:15
Elliot just left to go to a friend's
birthday celebration which is great
because we need one of us to retain some
ability to socialize with the outside
world and remember what that is like so
that when this is over it won't be as
jarring to re-enter into that part of
society crazier than that is that I just
made myself a nighttime pancake yeah I
am that
absolutely insane and it's not insane I
mean I am that clear on what I want out
of life today has been an
okay okayish day actually yeah today's
been a better day yesterday kind of
sucked emotionally I was very down on
myself um and then I just like spiraled
on top of that by just like letting
myself be on my phone mindlessly and
until it creates that very familiar
anxiety makes sense of that phrase like
people will choose a familiar hell over
an unfamiliar heaven today was a much
better day gave the dog bath vacuumed
washed the bedding for anyone out there
that has also done this can thing I get
super particular about things being
really clean like I never have before
I've been a generally clean person but
not I wish I was a cleaner person and
now I'm just really particular about
things that
like ick me out if they go a little long
without being clean like the bedding
garbage being taken out the dishes being
done the floors being vacuum maybe
that's just general cleanliness that
I've suddenly have become aware of I
don't know this thing has been pushing
me across thresholds that I never
thought I would be pushed across and um
General cleanliness is one of them I
guess this is probably unfortunate to
look at because of these glasses better
but now I don't get distance what if I
do it like that started to feel
emotionally a little better journaled
that always helps get the ick from the
brain out on the page then I just
forwarded that momentum into buying
Christmas decorations I have not been
much of a Christmas or holiday person
before Elliot is more than I am and I
decided this year why don't I get into
Christmas I got the time I'm not really
going anywhere and I could use a
creative outlet that doesn't require too
much of my brain function not to say
that decorating for Christmas isn't very
isn't an incredibly stimulating
cognitive exercise for
incredibly Adept people
I bought an artificial Christmas tree
and I bought some balls for it and I
bought some other bits and Bobs I think
I'm going to try to get into Christmas
this year we'll see meaning like maybe
you'll see maybe I'll yeah I got the
time I have not really been on social
media too much today wow how that makes
such a difference and then I wrote some
stuff down today my thoughts and I wrote
some jokes Loosely keeping jokes about
this situ ation in some notes to make a
bigger joke thing in the future
potentially it's just me now manifesting
it's new moon energy this is quite a
rambly clip and I want to eat my pancake
and watch 90day fiance now but just an
update that feeling better today have
some doctor's appointments tomorrow on
Wednesday still tired but doing okay
look at that woman from Harry
Potter ah the tea
leaves oh hello it's Wednesday and I put
some makeup on my face because cuz I'm
going to do therapy on zoom and I don't
want to look like the keeper I know
usually we do therapy on Tuesdays and
Thursdays this week we're doing
Wednesday and Friday because we were
seeing how I recover and I've had a
really knock on
wood why can't I oh my God you just
watched chemo brain in real time I don't
even know if I can like use chemo brain
as an excuse that just might be there's
a disconnect between my body and my
brain for sure after therapy been
wanting to shoot but I haven't felt well
enough and today I feel really excited
and well for it um I feel well for it a
video using all the new this might get
weird merch cuz we got new merch it's
freaking cute as heck I think it might
be my favorite launch of merch that
we've done and I'm going to make outfits
out of it because I've been in some
version of this and that Eagles
sweatshirt that you've seen for like 5
days straight look at this merch we got
I'm going to put in the descript
description the designer named Hannah
who designed our new logo for us I'll
put her Instagram because she's amazing
she's done a lot of designs for us and
we love her and look at that how cute
and there's a sweatshirt and it's all in
these bright Lisa Frank colors and then
this sweatshirt is so fun might be my
favorite one I don't know then there's
this t-shirt that's also fun and then
this is this just gives me Nickelodeon
Vibes and I just love it so we're going
to make a little fashion video because
we are the epitome of fashion if we say
it out loud it must be true all those
spiritual gurus keep quacking about that
so here it comes fashion girly era I
mean it's not starting I've been in it
okay I got to get ready for therapy okay
I just shot the fashion video and I'm
tired that took a lot more effort than I
thought it would because I was having a
good time I'm a little apprehensive
because I'm very skinny right now I've
lost weight because I have breast cancer
but I also am just like it I love
our merch a lot and I want people to see
how cute it can be I don't know there's
part of me that's like I don't want to
confront anyone with what I'm going
through but then there's also a big part
of me that like once to sincerely share
like this is what it looks like or at
least like what I'm willing to share
with you like there's a lot of emot
stuff that I don't turn a camera on and
film which I think is a healthy thing
but I can't escape being in my body
right now and the way it looks and it
looks kind of sick so obviously I have
that concern about confronting people
with that um but also there's just like
a big part I enjoyed getting all dressed
up for a little bit and I enjoy our
merch so that's what this one's about
though all those thoughts happen at the
same time all the time I'm going to rest
content creation is exhausting you guys
the Christmas decorating has begun look
at these cuties Amazon teal lights
Amazon reindeer and that is a Christmas
tree we will do this when the balls get
here ornaments Elliot has told me to
call them ornaments hello it is Thursday
morning 10:00 a.m. I'm sitting on the
floor of my office staying
grounded my office was a mess is always
a mess it's um controlled clutter we're
not here to criticize that I'm in the
same outfit I wore yesterday because the
hours of the day time also I think my
sweat glands have been affected I don't
really sweat in my armpits as much as I
did before is that a thing there's no
hair there anymore that's lovely I was
going through stuff in my office that I
was like trying to organize and I came
across this and I wanted to show you
this cuz this is such a cool and
beautiful gift hamt they make bags
purses clutches is purse an old term I
don't know they make bags I only heard
of Hammet because I got a gift of one of
their bags for working on a project
years ago and it was from a producer it
was just like such a nice beautiful gift
I've been carrying this brown little
backpack from Zara for maybe 5 years
maybe more back in October which was
Breast Cancer Awareness Month hamt dm'd
me on Instagram I never get DMS from
brands on Instagram if you're brand out
there please DM me I love like I I'm
available but they didn't ask me to do
anything they just said that they had a
rogue pink collection for Breast Cancer
Awareness Month part of the proceeds
were going to the breast cancer Alliance
and just for what I was going through
they wanted to send me one of the bags
and look at this bag look at this Rogue
pink little rogue pink bag that's cute
look at the Cadence it's made me take on
this is like a nice bag you want a nice
bag or you want to give someone a nice
bag hamt has great beautiful long
lasting stuff thank you Hammet I'm a
little inspired especially I playing
dress up yesterday to like you know
maybe dress up and carry nicer bags and
another thing that's happening today
that's really fun is there is this
botanical gardens The Hunton Gardens and
they have this Tea Room that I've been
wanting to go to for so long and I keep
making reservations and then I have to
cancel because I either don't feel well
or something's come up but today we have
a reservation at this Tea Room to go eat
little tea sandwiches and drink tea
maybe I should bring this cute B my gosh
I feel like my little teenage self is
like o look at you go and guess what
else we're doing today we're going to
shower it's Thursday last time we
showered was Monday it's about time big
day big day okay this is my outfit to
The Gardens and the t-o I don't know if
I like it but it is what it is I feel
comfortable I don't know if I'm going to
wear these blue blockers but they do
make me feel like I get to hide behind a
wall but they also make me feel like
Jons and that's also a good thing very
much doing genion cosplay it is what it
is let's go get some tea at a tea room
oh my
[Music]
God
I don't get it what's this baby being so
sneaky about look at that sneaky little
[Music]
baby like my little girls are this is
fun yeah we're both heing we're both
healing our inner little girl
[Music]
today
do I need my big glasses to feel okay on
camera no it's fine it's fine it is now
Friday oh my God that te- room was so
cute so delicious yes I had diarrhea
afterwards so worth it I'm doing okay
today wasn't the worst kind of uh the
golden standard for me now that wasn't
the worst digestive experience I mean I
really pushed my limit I went from
eating the most Bland foods to eating
every flavor available so you know I
knew what I was getting into and I
deserved everything I got which was a
great time and a mild amount of diarrhea
maybe I should leave that fancy tea room
my honest review but it's Friday and
look at what has sprung up in this house
testing this out here is oh with me wait
wait wait oh oh that's cute except it's
near food so I don't know I don't know
and then look what has exploded over
here whoa It's a pile of decorations for
a Christmas tree that is a Christmas
tree and I believe tonight we will be
decorating it because in this house we
are doing whatever the hell we want cuz
we have to take advantage of the moments
that I'm feeling really good and I am
feeling really good little bit of
diarrhea but
good thank you dishwasher for mimicking
how my butthole sounds we're not going
to stop there with the cuteness of
setting up oh wait I got distracted
there's some candles in there there's a
little thing right there there's a
little go right there Christmas is
happening I thought we're going to be
decorating a Christmas tree tonight that
sacon Suite let's make some cookies and
I asked Elliot last night what kind of
cookies he would want and he immediately
responded responded instantaneously Yes
he was a little high but instantaneous
response can you make homeme oatmeal
cream pies and I was like that's a great
idea I've never tried it before found a
recipe we're going to try to make
homemade oatmeal cream pies sounds so
sexual I can't think of cream pie
without we're a sweet Christmas family
so let's make some oatmeal cream
[Music]
pies
wow oh hello it's now Saturday no Tria
when I got done making the cookies I
realized I had been standing for like 2
hours straight and I was very I was a
tired girl I was I had to take a breast
cancer Break um and that break turned
into Elliott and I getting high and just
sitting on the couch and watching
television which was great but today
we're going to put up the tree Elliott's
on his way back from therapy because we
are a full function mental health house
I mop the floors and when he gets home
we're probably going to get extra cozy
and set up our Christmas tree
ah I feel like the Hulk but I'm just
like bloated on sweet cringe Hulk
wholesome I'm going to eat some lunch
before he gets here so I don't um pass
out from standing
up selfcare also we definitely ate two
cookies last night and they were the
most delicious
[Applause]
[Music]
thing
stage one of the tree has been finished
Elliot's getting changed into something
cute and I just B us the cutest little
shudy because everything's cute
everything is so cute in this
house uh-oh Christmas pants are on he's
dressed in his Christmas best we started
with a ribbon it's not done the stemming
isn't Dr up what's wrong with the tree
it's not looking quite naturally it's
too perfect it's artificial okay y all
right okay we're stopping for tonight
this is as far as we got which I think
is an excellent start wo look he's put
the lights all Christmas oh my god oh
hello it's now Sunday I'm wearing the
exact same thing as Saturday because
again time and I don't sweat that much
anymore thank you breast cancer not done
but we will get it done I've been
editing this Vlog for you all morning
and I didn't have an outro to it but wow
what a vlog we went to chemo you saw a
little bit of chemo recovery what it
looks like this round was a much more
pleasant round so showing you was a lot
easier than the previous rounds and you
don't need to see what happened in
previous rounds we went and got tea and
we decorated for Christmas so what a
lovely
spectrum of joyful and not so joyful
moments I'm going to end it so that I
don't have to do any more editing but I
hope you enjoyed this video I've been
really enjoying vlogging and getting
back into it a little bit it's Rusty but
I'm enjoying it I hope you are too I
have my last round of chemo oh my God my
last round of chemo in like a week and a
halfing crazy and then I will be
prepping for a surgery and then we
figure out after surgery we've been
working behind the scenes on all of that
kind of stuff too but so far fingers
crossed things are going okay my
holidays will be spent probably doing a
surgery or recovering from surgery but
that's fine I'm going to be in this
house which is becoming a Christmas
house so I'm setting myself up for
Success
um yeah ending a video we've always been
awesome at it and we continue to be
awesome at it all right see you next
time I pick up this camera